but there's one thing i have to do here
to make this feel more like an ndc
alexa turn the media room to purple it's
an ndc conference
okay so uh thanks for coming to the talk
this is fluxing up your.net apps and i'm
alex dunn
uh let's see if we can get this going so
you'll find me
online not as alex done i mean in some
capacity i will be but you'll find me
mostly a suave pirate
uh the reason for that is basically or i
should say the story behind that is
basically that my name
is so ordinary especially in the states
um i work a lot in the microsoft stack
and
net and there are multiple alex guns
that work at microsoft as developers
so i i use the name generator i wrote as
a kid we landed on swap pirate and
that's where i am all over the internet
so
on twitter on github even my linkedin
url
and most recently on twitch where i
stream every
wednesday and sunday building all sorts
of cool stuff we do a lot with
conversational ai and virtual assistants
mobile
and usually a whole bunch of.net i'm
also microsoft mvp.net tech and ai
uh and i'm also a pluralsight author
mostly talking about android development
and application development
uh so definitely check all that stuff
out so we're talking about
flux and we'll get into you know what
all of that means and what it is and
design patterns as a whole and
where we stand but uh you know like i
said this is talking about design
patterns and sort of high level
architect stuff so it'll help to know
there's sort of like two things
either have experience doing uh client
apps and dot net that could be
xamarin forms that could be uwp that
could be windows phone
uh if you're like me and and did that
back in the day i miss my windows phone
more than anything
familiarity with xaml is going to be
super helpful although even if you don't
have that we can always answer questions
on it
and then uh familiarity with mvvm and
bindings because we are going to be
doing
a lot of comparison uh especially
because i should say
until recently um the net
client-side app development cycle
between wpf uwp
and xamarin forms it's all about xaml
and nvvm and bindings and stuff like
that and we're going to try to
kind of break that mold a little bit in
this talk uh or
right that's that's the left half if
you're familiar with that
you're you're great you're gonna do
awesome here in this talk you should be
able to pick things up i'm talking about
if not ask questions
if you don't have that stuff and instead
you have familiarity with building
client apps in react that could be react
native that could be react for web
or if you're already familiar with flux
or redux or something like that
or at least object oriented javascript
you're going to do great because we're
talking about this stuff in dot net
but they're patterns that really
originated from
that side of the world of of development
from react
from uh the facebook team at the end
redux and flux and we'll get into all
that nonsense
i'm going to be putting these slides up
but just for some reference here
all the stuff we're going to be looking
at in demos it's all on github uh
online there's xamarin flux and we'll
get into a bonus demo
a little later as well uh which i didn't
want to spoil here
uh i also built an sdk for this that can
help a little bit just called the flux
toolkit for
net uh and then there's also some docs
here and then the original
uh xamarin university guest lecture
where i sort of brought this stuff into
the fold for the first time
but all that aside introductions aside
nice to see you all uh but let's get
into talking about what we sort of
currently see
in the application design pattern side
of things for the most part
and especially in the mobile world um
regardless of
net or not so as an example we have
a model view controller that's mvc and
so the structure of that is kind of like
this right we have our model that can be
everything on the data side and back we
have our controller which is then
responsible for handling the
communication between
our view so our controller can receive
data from requests from a view
and then it can send stuff back down to
manipulate that view that could be like
you know asp.net mvc that could be
ios which is sort of pushes you into an
mvc build with
view controllers uh but you can also
implement it wherever right it's just a
design pattern here where your
controller is responsible for basically
relaying information
uh to your view with both sending and
receiving data from your model
in the android world we have uh mvp
which is model view presenter
you'll notice that you know i'll go back
and forth between these two slides i
want to change one box because at a high
level it's the same thing
your model sits behind the scenes that's
your data your presenter is then in
charge
of choosing what is sent up and down
from your view
we also have model view view model which
is extremely common in the dot net space
wpf ewp
xamarin forms even in native stuff and
even across
other platforms as well mbvm is huge um
and basically this whole talk started
because i hate mvvm and i'm so sick of
it
and i hate the the verbosity and the
debugging of issues with it and stuff
and
all the problems i've had over the many
years of doing mvvm-based development
and that's sort of where we landed here
but either way my opinions aside
we we have the same general structure we
have our model
we have our view model which is then in
charge of doing that sending and
receiving a data to the view the only
difference between these three
right between mvc mvp and mvvm is like
the nuance of how they send and receive
data like mvvm it's usually done over
binding so
you're not doing like explicit sending
or receiving
instead you're binding properties
two-way and you're binding commands for
actions and things like that but either
way
in general it looks like this so let's
talk about problems with these
these design patterns let's talk about
problems with
mvvm especially so the first thing
uh whoops sorry about that the first
thing is this bi-directional data flow
so looking at these sort of core
components the model stuff is fine we
don't necessarily care about that
because our data's got to live somewhere
and it's got to be able to communicate
down to our view in
one way or another let's talk about this
bi-directional communication
between our view model and our view
between all of those patterns we saw
that we had that send and receive data
set up
and our view the the issues come when we
have
the bi-directional communication that's
hard to sort of like
separate that relationship between our
view model and our view
is actually pretty tightly coupled even
if it's really not meant to be and we
try to tell ourselves it isn't
we have that tight coupling of our view
to our view model now
beyond the bi-directional issues we also
have what i call cross-based it's really
like in this scenario where i have a
view model all over the place
it's about cross-view models so in an
app like an actual production app or
anything else even just one with
multiple pages
this is generally what your architecture
is going to look like you've got
multiple view models that are tied to a
view
and they send and receive data but
there's no rules
that really dictate how these should be
communicating to each other
so a lot of times what we see is a
diagram that sort of looks like this
and view models can just send stuff to
each other and this is sort of like an
early stage of people learning mvvm i
see this sort of implementation a lot
uh with folks that aren't familiar with
abstractions and
service layers and things like that so
we go from this sort of messy
mesh of view models just sending stuff
to each other and it's hard to keep
rules around that and it's hard to track
down bugs when something goes wrong
so then that the sort of natural next
rule
is to add a service layer an abstraction
over it
but this rule isn't strict and we can
get a little better
we can use dependency injection we can
inject
our service layer into our view models
so now we can handle sending stuff up
and down there
that's sort of helping mostly separate
the
model from the view model not so much
that cross model communication
but it certainly can some examples of
that would be like
um the uh like navigation service
pattern right when we want to navigate
to another page
we don't just say from our view model go
open this page although
i do see that all the time but you're
not supposed to do that um
we see like you inject a navigation
service and you say navigation service
navigate to this page
and that will handle setting up the view
and the view model and everything else
um there's another layer you can take to
this you can abstract your data access
layer so now you've got a nice
separation of like
data layer business logic layer view
state layer and view and that's great
um but there's still no rules around it
and it still
sort of leads to making it difficult to
run it especially in a team environment
uh building and managing apps at scale
that
can easily sort of start to fall apart
because that relationship between your
service layer and viewmodel layer
if you're not setting really good rules
around it someone can just implement
something wrong
and then we run into issues with
tracking it down
now that's all just from the view model
up we also have difficulty
testing and debugging the actual
bindings you know the bindings are meant
to
abstract your view model and your views
relationship that's the whole goal of it
but
that cool comes with consequences or
that that feature comes with
consequences and essentially
it's that if you run into an issue with
the binding it's a pain to figure out
i'm sure some of you have had in the
past and other times if you set it up
right you don't necessarily have to
worry about it
but usually that separation and
especially doing things over like
string property relationships and stuff
makes it really difficult
so for example i could just have like a
typo in
my binding of a property and like not be
aware of it like
even if it's like case sensitive and i
just like didn't capitalize the name of
the property i'm binding to
in some scenarios that will be caught by
uh build
issues but even in that scenario i might
not just
realize right away like oh i typed this
with a lowercase instead of pascal
casing it
um and that is just annoying it
feels like a problem that us as
developers can get around it and not
have to worry about
uh and then lastly there's difficulty in
testing and debugging
that service layer relationship to the
view model now
if you're doing dependency injection
properly that doesn't necessarily mean
it's really difficult you do have the
ability to unit test very easily now you
can mock your service layer and test
certain scenarios
but when it comes to that real world
implementation where there's sort of
this like mystery
of what's happening behind the scenes
between these two view models
communicating
that's where we run into issues in
production with trying to understand
what's happening right
so let's talk about where flux comes in
and how it can actually help with some
of these scenarios so i'll introduce the
concept in general
uh and then we'll talk about how it
works in those uh specific cases to help
fix it
so at a high level here's sort of my my
go-to bullet points been talking about
flux
it's a client-side application and uh
application architecture and design
pattern
meaning that it's just another sort of
tool
in your tool belt there are libraries
that are there to
to help with this you know like i said i
built one for net
mostly for like my xamarin apps but in
general it's just a concept
there's no like hard implementation of
it
that you need to use every time i'm not
here to promote a library or something
like that it's just a design pattern
it was originally set up by facebook and
for helping build like really large
scale and robust
data driven uis so this is where we
start to get into like massive scale of
an app and like
when i say scale i mean like the actual
like features
within the ui and the app and the data
within it itself right like
facebook built these insanely functional
applications from facebook itself to
messenger to like
the other 30 they have so basically
their
original implementations of state
management and react when they were
getting that started just wasn't enough
so they introduced this design pattern
um and it really helps a lot with that
the focus is on the flow of data and
separation of concerns
there are other patterns out here that
are very much like this and
tools that try to help with these same
things and same with the that next
bullet point there are the
unidirectional data flows
um and that could be like reactive uh or
reactive
uh it keeps trying to say like the js
one but
reactive ui extensions would help with
this in the whole reactive pattern in
general it's the same goal of like
having that single flow of data and just
listening to events propagate through
but this just sort of implements some
more rules on it as well
so if you've come from the react world
there's some sort of nomenclature i want
to translate over when we talk about it
in uh these samples that we're going to
do with c-sharp and xamarin later so for
example a components render function
in react is the same as having your
actual page right that's your your raw
ui
the component state we're still going to
actually use a view model in data
binding to make the
most use out of what we have there the
props are properties that's no different
and then the component life cycle of
like component will mount or did mount
component will unmount stuff like that
and react that's just the same as the
page life cycles like on navigated2 on
navigated away or
or uh can never remember the ones for
the other platforms but
either way it's there's a pretty good
pairing here with how we're talking
about this translation
so let's talk about the structure like
what flux really is and
it's really made of four main components
and that's all you have to think about
there are actions and an action
basically
does some business logic and then
communicates to the dispatcher right our
little guy over here
on the right side the dispatcher then is
responsible for taking information from
the action
so the action does whatever it needs to
and says hey dispatcher
dispatch this thing and the dispatcher
is going to say all right let me go send
all of that information to whatever
stores you have
these stores take the information from
the dispatcher regardless of where it
came from
does something to update the state of
the data that's within it
and then it's going to propagate or emit
those changes
down to the views that are subscribed to
it so there's sort of like
a three level subscription here an
action
happens we don't care where that came
from we send stuff to the dispatcher
explicitly the action literally calls
the dispatcher
stores subscribe to dispatchers and
views subscribe to stores
meaning that a store can be thought of
as sort of like an abstracted view model
across
all your stuff that's really just
focused on data structure and not
view data structure so action to
dispatcher
dispatcher to store store to view and
it's just that that single
sort of circle there like we said
focused on a unidirectional data flow
and everything sort of follows suit
there so
what that means is your app architecture
instead of going from like that
cascaded set of like views and view
models with
the bi-directional thing it's just a
whole bunch of these loops
so you have one set up where you have an
action to dispatcher to store the view
and then you have another one and really
your whole app is just a collection of
these loops
and it's a really interesting way to
think about
your your structure of your data in the
app the structure of your state and the
structure of your views
it's really just a collection of these
loops which means they're really easy to
follow
because if you run into an issue with
just one of those you just go into where
that whole sort of loop happens and
you're good to go
now let's talk about adjusting it for
the sort of mvvm in the dot net world
because
in its current state we have xaml for
our primary way of building views and we
have the benefit of data bindings using
that
benefit could be you know debated but i
like to think it's at least useful
so the only difference here is that
instead of just having the store
listen to the uh or have the view
listened to the store
we instead have a view model listen to
it and our view model just communicates
bi-directionally to our view
uh but the rest of it is still the same
instead of having the view actually
execute an action we just leave that to
the view model
so really we're sort of combining these
two uh design patterns because they fit
pretty well together
we let the view and view model be its
state and view
we don't have to really worry about like
two-way bindings we can do like one-way
bindings
but then we get all the benefit of the
state management and the sort of
high-level abstraction of our
data and our state within our app and we
let flux take care of that we let our
stores keep that as our source of truth
we let our actions be the ones that
dictate when something's changing
and we let our dispatchers sort of
handle the communication
is that all making sense so far before
we dig into it like i said if you guys
have questions throw them in the chat
so like i promise we're going to talk
about those those problems that we had
with the other architectures or
design patterns like mvvm and how flux
can make those a bit easier
um so the first thing we get and we've
talked about this now a few times is
that unit direction
of of data flow meaning that we don't
have to worry about the mysterious
issues of two-way bindings we can
enforce a single direction
if the view model needs to update
something on the view
that views property should not be able
to update the same property on the view
model it should be one way either from
the view to the view model or from the
view
from the view mode to the view or the
view to the view model so for example
even if we're binding to like a label
right it's just a label or text block if
you're in the
wpf uwp world if you have a text block
your binding should only come one way
from the view model if you're doing a
text input like a text box or
an entry then it should only go from the
view to the view model
if you make a change in your view model
you want to avoid making that
as a two-way binding it should always be
one way and that way we can enforce that
full control from mvvm all the way
through the flux process and follow that
track of the data
in one direction we also get trickle
down control and
we're going to go into some more
diagrams in case you didn't get enough
of the ones so far
um and the the trickle down control is
one of the most useful parts of it
because
it also makes it easy to follow what's
happening but also hit that really large
scale
of data and views we have a single
source of truth if we have something
wrong with our state
we don't have to go find what view model
like changed and what happened we just
go to the store
each store owns its dtos it's data
models we know if something goes wrong
we go there we fix what's happening with
our data and we move on
and it plays well with other ui patterns
like we just said it works really well
with mbbm in this scenario
but it also i think more importantly
plays well with other sort of system or
architecture
design patterns such as dependency
injection
mocking and everything else that makes
that testability really easy to control
that's one of the benefits of having
that separation of concerns that we get
from like mvvm and nbc and
like we talked about before dependency
injecting the service layer and data
layer
we can still get all those benefits and
it works really well and we'll take a
look at that in the demos as well
so but let's talk about the that trickle
down control so like we talked about the
single flow right an action
talks to the the dispatcher dispatcher
sends stuff to the stores that are
listening to it
and the stores update the views or the
view models uh
via a subscription sort of model now
that doesn't have to be a single sort of
loop there that doesn't mean that
one view can only call one action which
can only hit to an event that only one
store listens to
your views can technically affect each
other
uh by having multiple subscriptions
happen so like in this case we have an
action that happens we don't care where
it came from
action one send something through the
dispatcher right let's just say it's
like an item added event
that we just tell the dispatcher this is
happening we can have two stores listen
to the same event so now we've got store
one and store two
listening to this event and store one is
being
subscribed to by two different views so
this one action
actually could affect three completely
different views now in the world of
dot net client apps that could be full
pages
and we're even updating stuff behind the
scene or that could be like sub
components and stuff like that
so let's get into some more complex
scenarios one view
can fire two different actions so we've
got action one action two
v1 sends says both of these actions are
going to happen
we also have two different stores so
action one
is being dispatched the dispatcher takes
it and store one and two are both
listening to it
but store two is only listening to
action two and store one is not
then view one and view two are listening
to different relationships between store
one and two so once again like
one underlying view just affected a
whole bunch of stuff
but it's all just trickled down it all
runs through the dispatcher to our
source of truth which is our stores
and then we're able to basically go take
a look at our views and and see what's
going on
now here's an important note that i
always want to emphasize we always talk
about the the sort of pure
flux flow of a view sends an action to
the dispatcher to the store
back to the view but views are not the
only thing that can execute
actions so for example we've got this
scenario here
back to the sort of net example where
we've got our view and view model
totally separate and vm style with
single wave bindings
view models can send stuff to actions
that's great that's our perfect
beautiful super easy flow that we've got
set up
but i could have a background event also
fire in action and it could be the same
action
so some examples of that we have a
websocket connection and this is where i
i really dug into the sort of uh flux
scenario for the first time
building a real-time chat app so if i
am typing a message in the app and i hit
send that's an action from a view and it
sends it to the dispatcher we say hey
we're sending a message
the action maybe sends that to a server
that does something with it
the dispatcher then goes hey we have a
new message to add the store goes hey i
got your message you just sent let me
add that to local state so now your
message is going to be propagated to
your viewmodel and it's going to show up
in your list
but when someone else sends that
information or sends a message from
their app
we receive that over something like a
websocket event
so now i sent my message and that stays
within the loop
if i receive a message from you your
message can just fire an action the same
way that me sending it does and that
means i just get the event i say
from my my code let's say we're using
something like signalr
we're subscribing to an event on like
message received we say hey on message
received just goes
fire this action and that's all we have
to care about we don't have to say hey
on message received go
do this thing and put it in state and
then like let's make sure that actually
updates the view
we just say we gotta we got that
websocket event fire the action
and the rest of it's handled by our
setup the same way that it is if the
event came from the view
uh another example of that is like a
location update event if you're building
a
map app your update could come from
the user changing the position of the
map or it could come from
their actual location changing on their
device which is not directly from a view
similarly from an accelerometer event so
if i'm doing something and moving my
phone
in this scenario those events that are
firing in the background can update the
state and update the view simply by just
saying hey this action happened right
on the other side of things views or
view models in this case
are not the only things that can
subscribe to stores
right again we've talked about the
perfect flow view action dispatcher
store
but in this scenario the view model
isn't the only thing that can listen to
a change of state
we might have a background task that we
want to execute whenever we actually
uh fires and update from our store so we
could have a view
execute a command on our view model
which then fires an action globally
it does its business logic the
dispatcher takes that and says hey store
you this event just happened here's the
data go update your state
but a great example of this would be
like doing a data sync remotely
so when my local state updates i could
also go update my
state across my apis or something like
that and i think that use case is really
really interesting because
you know the the sort of offline data
syncing has been a challenge in the
mobile world that no one has done really
well in a long time
and this is the first solution that i've
had that i was actually really happy
with with the way that it was set up
because it makes it super easy to say
like my app state can also just be over
here in some remote data sync but it can
also
be just updating like a local database
so if i have my
my local state in the store in memory i
can also
go update that on an actual like sql
light or
some sort of document store just on my
device
which you know it's an amazing setup to
have because i now don't have to care
about the rest of that flow but i know
if something goes wrong with
setting local data i go to my source of
truth which is my state
in the store
cool so assuming that all makes sense
i hope you guys are are done with block
diagrams because i sure am
um so let's talk about an actual demo
so uh what i'm going to walk you through
is a xamarin forms app
that uses flux and mvvm like we talked
about
and also in version of control and
dependency injection
all of this stuff is on github uh you
can go grab it from my github it's
slash swap pirate xamarin.flux if you
want to follow along
uh but i'll talk you through the the
project structure before we really
dig into the code itself and start to
run this thing
so we we have a basic sort of
xaml.net standard xamarin forms template
it's the usual stuff
we have our uh dotnet center library we
have an android
project and we have an ios project
everything that we're doing fluxside is
all in the shared code right so we're
still getting the benefits of everything
else we do where we don't really have to
worry about like
android specific stuff or ios specific
stuff um but let's talk about like
the flux specific components in here so
we have our actions in a folder we have
an i action and a to do action
we have an action type for to do action
types it's basically just like
identifiers for what the action is we
have our model
which is a to do app we have our startup
stuff which is all like inversion of
control config for dependency injection
and all that good stuff
and then we have our store in this case
we have
the event args for it we have a base
class to handle some of the binding
stuff
and we have our uh to do store
and then we have our view models we have
a view model locator for pulling it out
for dependency injection so we can just
actually bind directly to an injected
version of the v model
we have our to-do list page view model
and then below that we have our views
so what we're actually creating here is
a super basic app your
most traditional basically hello world
in
in the mobile world of creating a to-do
app so we can do things like viewer
items we can create items by giving it a
name
we can then say that it's uh toggle to
complete or not
we can delete them we can edit them we
can populate it with a whole bunch of
stuff
um we we can delete all of the ones that
are completed
and we can toggle all of them to true or
false right so like in theory we should
be able to say like
hey all of these are complete now also
wipe them
um so let's go take a look at the actual
source code
so what i wanted to do see if this is
the right one i've got two versions of
it up right now this is the this is not
the one i don't want to spoil it
so we've got um this empty solution here
and what i want to show is that
instead of showing you what it looks
like in the end
i want to show you what it looks like
without all of the flux stuff
so let me start by going into views and
let's go take a look at our to-do list
view so everything we just saw
right now this is no flux this is just a
pretty straight up
mvvm scenario let me know if that's big
enough to view too i can always change
it
but essentially what we have here is a
single page and we've got a list view
and we've got our binding context set up
which is saying that we're going to go
to our static resources locator and get
that to-do list page i'll show you where
that lives in a second
we then have our toolbar items for like
populating uh creating a new one
clearing the ones that are completed and
toggling all of them as either
completed or not completed our list view
is then binding to the items property of
our to-do list page
and then our data template is just a
text
cell where we're just saying get the
text of the to do item
and if it's complete we're using a
string format to say
it is complete true or false we then
also added context
actions to these to be able to delete
them toggle them or edit them
and that basically exists as
a like on android it'll be like a tap
and hold thing and it changes the
toolbar out
and on ios that exists as
the like swipeable things although you
can do that on both now
i'm also just getting my phone set up so
that way i can actually run it for you
and show you on visor
i'm running on windows right now so it's
going to be hard for me to show you the
ios app
i don't have my mac running right next
to me but i'll be able to show you
android
let me clear all these so anyway that's
our view
um let's go take a look at our view
model that's behind it
so we have a to-do list page view model
um
looks like it just didn't grab my stuff
and see if i can just build it
uh just so we can get rid of some of
these squiggles
oh cool
yeah i know i don't i don't have it set
up on this machine um
cliff uh for using hot restart in
xamarin
uh that and i also don't have my iphone
next to me uh to be able to run so i
would need to run it on the simulator
um okay either way i mean it's gonna
look exactly the same it's like the most
basic app in the world
one that arguably should not be over
architected with flux uh let me try to
figure out why
all of a sudden i got all these
squiggles when i ran this this morning
let me restore nuget packages here i
mean i can talk through it with the
squiggles either way
um
[Applause]
rebuild all failed that's lovely okay
either way we'll let's just talk through
it and ignore the squiggles
so we have a uh private observable
collection
we have commands for the create toggle
toggle all delete
um and i wanted to make this as like
unopinionated as possible in terms of
like
frameworks and libraries there are much
simpler ways to do this stuff now
like you could just use fodie to handle
the way that i'm doing like the
i notified property change for the mvvm
but like i said
i didn't want to introduce libraries
that people might not understand in the
sample so
we have the create command and basically
we're just using the relay command from
nvvm lite
uh and then we're using alan richie's
user dialogues uh
which is like the first library i always
add in every xamarin app i ever
build uh to be able to say from here we
just want to prompt the user
um with some actions and then we're
going to create
our our to-do from here and then
basically we
register all these commands and they all
actually do the business logic within
them so you'll see
like in this case we get the items and
we
take the first one and we update the
text and
if we delete it then we just remove it
from the items and this items is our
observable collection which means when
we bind to it any changes
made um to our observable collection
behind the scenes will also propagate
because we're two-way binding everything
so that's all it is we just have that
list and we have all of these commands
that are
actually changing things on it now let
me walk you through the setup
so from the app xaml
we register a viewmodel locator which
is uh going to be registered as a static
resource called locator which is why in
our page
we can set the binding to locator and
then we're going to grab the specific
properties off of it
so if we go look at that locator we're
basically saying like go
get an instance of our to-do list page
view model and
we'll get the other one to build because
i have it running right now
um but essentially we're just saying go
get me an instance of this which will
handle all of the dependency tree
crawling and creating and stuff like
that
um and then our ioc config basically
says that we can register actions and
stores which we'll get into
and then we can register our view model
so our view model doesn't need anything
injected into it because everything is
just running from here everything is
just local state within a view model
now that means if we wanted to do more
with this such as like creating a new
page for editing the details instead of
doing it all on one
we have to be able to start passing
those parameters around
handle understanding the state in an
abstraction so like
if i edit the name on a different page
how do i make sure that that name is
edited when i get back to this view
model that's the sort of challenge that
we can solve with flux
uh let's get out of this one because i'm
sick of all the red squiggles
um and i was hoping to be able to
actually type some of this up but it
seems like those builds are gonna be
annoying so we'll just walk through the
completed one
um so like i said we have all these
things now added
the original one was just the viewmodel
and the view and the viewmodel locator
in this startup
so we added a few more things here we
have our actions
action types and stores those are the
biggest changes and then we also have
some new things set up in ioc config
so let's first go take a look at our
to-do list page view model
so the biggest differences here are that
we still have all these commands
but we we also now have private read
only to do store
and to do actions now the reason for
that is again like our view model
is able to execute actions so we need a
reference to the class that controls
these specific actions because we can
sort of scope them into our domain
we then also need a reference to the
store that way we can subscribe to
changes to it
and be able to update uh the things that
are happening behind the scenes and then
we also have our items and we have the
same commands
and the biggest difference within each
one of these commands such as the create
command
is that we're not actually changing that
items property anymore
we're not saying okay we're going to
create it so tell the
items to add a new one instead we just
say hey to do actions we're
sending we're adding a new to do and
here's the text that the user entered
same thing for edit we just say we do
the prompt in the ui because this is
all ui-based stuff and we say hey
actions that we edited this one here's
the id and here's the text
toggling we're just saying hey toggle
this one by its id
uh toggle all just sends an action to do
all of them you'll basically see like
all of these commands are now just
abstracted into our actions
uh this could be done even more
abstracted where basically we don't even
have the commands and the commands
actually exist within the actions but
that could be a little bit overkill um
and then let's go take a look at the
actual updates here
so the biggest difference is uh our
constructor now actually takes
dependencies
so we're injecting a to do store and to
do actions and we set those
but now we're also subscribing to this
on omitted event
if you remember the flow we have an
action that calls to the dispatcher
our dispatcher then sends events out and
our
stores can listen to them but then our
stores emit those events once they're
done updating their state they need to
let everyone know like hey we're good to
go like go get all the latest stuff
um so that's where we handled this
subscription so now our view model down
here
we can do basic switches or you can
handle this with better typing but in
this case we're grabbing the event type
which is a string
and we have that list of to do action
types like i mentioned before and these
are all just identifiers that are unique
everywhere across everything
yeah yeah brandon thanks we're already
running into issues with our first demo
i'm not even gonna try to get hot
restart working
um so uh in this in these events right
we have our ad to do
and when we get that event emitted right
this is the event that we fired from the
beginning from the action from here but
when it comes all the way back around at
the end of that loop
we're just going to toast to say like
hey we added this item
hey we deleted these ones and you can
see for each one of these we're
basically just letting the user know
that that
command happened or if we get an error
we can also handle that in the ui state
so that means that we can handle errors
at the global
state level and not have to worry about
that maybe necessarily making them view
specific although we can certainly have
both if you have error messages you need
to show that like something happened in
the ui
and aren't related to data that's fine
um but we can actually take
all of the errors just as something
that's an observable part of the state
from the store
so if some action came through and
something went wrong we can let you know
that that something happened and i'll
try to demo that a little bit as well
so let's start from the top and sort of
follow along with this flow
um and we can step into let's say this
add to do
so we are dependency injecting our to do
actions
and we can now step into this ad to do
now here's an interesting thing about
xamarin forms in particular
is that we essentially kind of have a
dispatcher
built into the tooling although i heard
rumors of this being deprecated
so if that's the case the toolkit i put
together also has a dispatcher but we
have the messaging center in xamarin
forums which is really cool
so that means that we can just say hey
messaging center uh
dispatch this event right the messaging
center is our dispatcher you get one
dispatcher for your entire app it's
perfect it fits exactly with our flux
model and we already have the tool
we're saying like hey we're going to
fire uh this from our i
actions and we're going to send along
the type of string
so basically we're saying that go fire
this action
type or dispatch this event we did the
ad to do and here's the value
now you could always do some other
things in here in terms of like the
business logic that we talked about
to do's can do or certainty is reading
the wrong word actions can actually do
things they're not necessarily just
there for omitting events
so for example here we could do
something like send the
new to do item to an api
and then once it's done
then dispatch the event
some people like to do it this way where
the sort of external
um applications are or actions are
firing and doing all that here some
people actually like to do that
uh in the uh in the stores and have that
all just related to state logic
um but in this case like we can always
do more but because again this is the
most simple app all we're worrying about
is just doing the dispatch at the end
but essentially an action's
responsibility
is to do whatever it needs to do first
and then tell the stores
here's what you need from this action
and here's the data
so this is where the biggest separation
is because we dependency injected this
which means we can already separate that
we can
mock this out we could always just
inject i actions separately
um but the biggest separation is that
from here
this action has no idea what stores are
actually listening to the events that
it's dispatching
so let's go take a look at our to-do
store
so a store basically is just an
observable
collection of data but it's not
observable in the way that it's like a
two-way setup or
we're using like a reactive setup and
doing chaining of observables
it's very sort of explicit uh or verbose
so we have this base store which
basically i just set up with a generic
type this is in that toolkit just you
know like if you don't want to write
this yourself but
we have a base store of type t we have
that on omitted event that's what our
view models we're listening to
we have the t type of data that's the
observable part here you could always
have other
data structures in here too that are
observable it doesn't have to be one
property
uh in this case this is a very basic one
and then we also are keeping track of
the error
now we also have the emit event and we
admit it by calling the animated.info
if it's actually registered and then we
also have the ability here to handle the
subscriptions to
the different types of events so
basically when we create a store
uh what we do is to do store
in the constructor we're saying hey
we're going to subscribe to these events
from the dispatcher
so subscribe to the ad to do when the
dispatcher says that a to do is added
and it's going to pass in a string we
want to handle that
so that subscription is then going to go
all the way through this receive event
and this is also generic so we have this
type data but this type
this t data is going to match whatever
we put in here and it could also be
empty like in some of these cases
but let's say like in the case of the
add to do when we get the
type coming through of ad to do we're
going to go and update that data so this
is similar to what we were doing
previously
just in the view model but now we're
doing it here in the store
so now we do that for each of our other
types and basically we can just cast the
data type to what we explicitly need
um and then if anything happens in an
exception we're setting the state of the
error
but all the way under that we're always
going to call the receive event which is
where our
emitting happens that sends it back down
to the view model which means all of our
logic here
for updating local state happens it all
runs first because we don't want to tell
the view models that something's ready
when it's not
and then at the very end it's emitted so
that means even if something is thrown
we're going to get that error now
what i want to do is show you just one
more thing and then we'll run this
um well i'm just getting my
my phone set up here so the other things
that we the only other things we change
is that instead of just registering the
view model for dependency injection we
also registered a store
uh in the actions you could always just
register all of your other stores here
that way they can all be injected and
stuff like that
but some other points to sort of
demonstrate that we talked about
um view models can listen to multiple
stores all i'd have to do in this case
is just inject another store type here
and we can listen to it it can also send
to multiple different action types
it's up to you how you sort of like
scope your stores and your actions
some people prefer to create a store for
every data type which is what this model
fits well because you just get that data
property in the generic
and that's all you have to worry about
and some people prefer to scope their
stores to more of a domain
and it fits really well with ddd in that
scenario where your domain
of of information is within the store
and that way your views can also be
aware of what domain they belong to
as well and that's how you sort of
bridge that abstraction gap
to say like in this case if we had the
to do item and as one of our domains
then we know that the to do store is
going to have everything we need around
that domain and we can worry about it
there but in this case
it's so simple we've just got one type
that we're worried about
and we're off and running so let me get
visor running
hopefully it'll behave with me
and we're going to spin this up and
actually debug it
so what i want to do is i'm going to add
a breakpoint
in our create
just waiting for it to spin up before i
show you my screen although
look how cute my dog is looking at me so
handsome
all right we're halfway through building
here so we're just gonna step through
and you can sort of see the whole flow
the important thing though is that i
can't just step through all the way to
here
so what i'm going to want to do is add a
break point uh to this side as well
we're just about done and at least this
one we don't have squigglies and
everything's building and deploying
all right let's pull up our app here so
we've got an empty list
if i go to create a new one we get that
dialogue thank you alan for all of your
work on this
and i will say that this is hello ndc
that's my to-do item
so i clicked done which means that we
got the results so just to sort of show
you the state of what's going on here
our prompt results that we got the text
hello ndc so we're going to tell our
to-do actions that we're adding one with
this text
so if we step into this we're now going
to send over the messaging center
that we're going to admit or dispatch
this event the ad to do
with this text value so we have 10 we
land here so now we're within our to do
store
we've received our event and we're going
to check the event type in this case
that's that add to do
identifier and our data is the string
hello ndc
so we're going to end up in this case
and we're going to add to our data which
is currently an empty
collection and then we're going to come
down here and we're going to call
receive event which if we step
into and we're going to call that emit
which then is actually emitting the
invoke so let me go add
a breakpoint down here
so in our view model now the full loop
has happened
our view model called the action the
action dispatched the event to the store
the store has
updated its data and now when we step
through we're going to switch over it's
still the same action type
we don't have an error so we're going to
toast that item was added
let me pull this back up here so you can
see that item added down here at the
very bottom and we have our item
actually added
oh man i'm on the free version okay
now let's let me show you sort of that
error state as well
so like i said managing errors in apps
is surprisingly difficult especially at
large scale but if we let our stores
handle the scope of those errors
then we can get really really far with
it so for example
in our to do store we have this catch
down here if something goes wrong with
our data locally we're going to catch
that and set the state of the error but
we're still going to emit it
so i'm just going to go up here and
we're going to throw an exception
throw new exception and we'll set the
message to be like
whoops that means none of this stuff's
going to run
the second we get to receiving the event
we're going to throw an exception
what i want to show is this breakpoint
all right we're back up and running
so this will happen on any event that i
trigger so i'm just going to hit like
the populate button here
we're going to throw our exception so
now we still omitted the event
so we're in our view model back here
again on our store omitted
the event type was still add to do
because that was what happened but we
have an error so we don't want to say
that the item was added
instead we fall into this case where we
do have an error and we have whoops
which means that i can now do an alert
with that error and manage that in state
just oh this is going to run for a whole
bunch of them because i
did the one that does a ton of actions
let me get rid of these break points
oh no i shouldn't have used the populate
one it's sending like a thousand of
these
okay so we've got i think 20 error
messages that just popped up
um and if i just keep slapping okay you
can see the shadows
slowly dissolve which i always think is
funny
uh but that's how we handle our errors
so that's all of the sort of basics
of the flux setup now that's all xamarin
forms with the mvvm side so now
you know i promised some some bonus demo
stuff
uh so let's let's talk about uh our
bonus demo which
is going to be sort of a comment maui
environment
um with with flux now
this is also on on github uh it's under
comment.flux i originally did this way
before maui was even announced even
before it was announced
at mvp summit um and it's
using the experimental side of comet
which is then going to be folded into
maui
and really common is just an entirely
new way
of thinking about state management and
building uis and building apps
really um and so what i have here is
that video and i can play it again
um where we have a similar thing where
we can add to do items and we can toggle
them
but this is all running on comment now
let me uh
take you all over there so comment was
built by clancy
he's uh one of the smartest people i've
ever met
uh doing some wonderful things with net
uis
and the idea here is that instead of
having
that mvvm as sort of the forefront of
the
um state pattern we have mvu which is
model view update
now that's a single directional chain
and you'll see even here in the
there in clancy's block diagram our
model is
is still our model and it executes our
state changes to our views
and instead of using like two-way
bindings we uh
update the view directly and then it's
all this sort of single direction and
all you can have sort of scoped state
management
and abstracted state management mvu is
the design pattern that react
uses react.js uses which is why flux is
like the perfect fit for that it's
exactly why it was created in the first
place for
abstracted state management and now it's
going to become even more useful
as a pattern to use when using this mvu
style of dot-net development
so just to talk through some of these
samples here now we've only got
basically 10 minutes left so
i want to make sure i cover enough of
this our view is actually
using a c sharp composition uh to
generate it and then
we manage our state it has hot reload
built in but
anyway to get down to our view we have
state which we wrap in whatever object
type we want in this case it's an
integer
and we call it the state object uh and
then if we want more complex stuff we
can create binding objects and mark that
as state with this attribute
and then basically what happens is
anytime something that is either
a basic type of state or an object type
of state whenever that object is updated
we're going to basically recalculate our
view and re-render it
so here's a great example here where we
have this page it has a vertical stack
layout so just
two things right under each other we
have text which is a label
and it takes the text of hello world and
then we have a button
that's called update and its text is
called update text and
what it has here is basically it's click
handler now this is an actual
delegated function and what we say is uh
grab the state.txt
right so we've got this and
we we basically say like to update the
text here
of this button instead of being update
text going to update it to click count
and we're updating it to click count uh
dot value plus plus which means that
literally in this setup we're
technically updating this state value
by sort of throwing this plus plus here
and that's actually going to propagate
and recalculate the view
so that this update text or this one
rather is going to be
grabbing that new click count which is
really cool so it's all just like
sort of hyper local state that single
loop of things now
the other cool thing about comet and
eventually the tooling in maui
is that we don't have to use visual
studio in all of the sort of ui
components
in of building things instead we can use
uh where to go comment.looks
we can use vs code so i'm literally
going to just say opening code here
when we expand this xamarin.flux.com
example
um we have the same setup where we've
got actions and stores
right our to-do store is exactly the
same as it was in our other example
uh let me actually actually is fine so
we have the same subscription events we
have our data it's initialized to an
empty list
it's the same receive event it runs
through the same logic
all of that is just as usable as it is
with the mvvm setup as it is with
the comment setup because the flux side
of things is an abstraction on top of it
and especially when it comes to the
stores this store doesn't care
what view hit it or what was executing
it it just cares about managing its
state
uh our views though are simplified
there's no viewmodel folder anymore
instead we just have our main page so
our main page is then
uh either dependency injected or set up
with
a new store in actions so that view
model part of it is gone we are now in
more of that sort of like pure
flux setup where we have our state as
the local list of to-do's we have our
actions in our store
we're generating a new list uh for the
state which is based off of the to do
stores data
so we're saying that this new list which
you'll notice is a list and not an
observable collection
of to do's and we're grabbing the to do
source data which is also a list of to
do's and we're also doing that
subscription to the onomitted
basically same thing we saw in the other
one where
we don't have to necessarily worry about
all of the
um state management locally instead we
just receive the event from the store
in this case we're console writing
instead of using alan ricci stuff
because
it's not built for comment and we're
just saying reset state which is
basically like hey when we get this ad
to do just like go recalculate stuff
now we could also you know just done
this down here at the very end
and we can just get rid of all of these
basically to say like hey when
when we uh receive an event of any kind
go update the state and basically
recalculate everything
so we console rightline at this is added
and then our state is recalculated here
when we call reset state
and we're saying that the list of
to-do's is also just going to be that
uh the list of data from our store so
this is like much more explicit with the
way that flux is also built in
react and then down here with our view
render
we have a button called add and the
button for toggle all like we saw and
then we have this list
and we're just passing in that value uh
of our state so this is a list and we
pass it in within a frame
and so now whenever we update it right
whenever we call reset state
whenever this property is changed at all
like we do here when we're setting it to
get to the new to do stores data
all of this gets recalculated which
means we recalculate the to-do list view
and we pass in the new list and then
this to-do list view is is literally
just like a
it's a stack of of things it's not even
like an actual like
pure list view um but we we register it
inherits from list view of the certain
type uh we take in that i
uh list of to-do's that we passed in
from our actual pages component but now
this view can also contain its own state
if we wanted to and it's really
nice for building uh that sort of
componentized structure
so you know i'm i'm personally really
really excited for this
future of net client app development
um you know supporting still the mvvm
stuff but this mvu
way of developing is so nice it's so
much easier for building
componentized and composed um
uis the way that uh people that use
react to
and and for managing your state in more
attracted ways and getting access to
easier implementations of other
design patterns uh i'm personally really
excited for this that's why i really
wanted to dive into the comet side
um it's funny i first learned about this
right before i gave this talk
last year when this was still like super
experimental
um and i was like oh my gosh this is way
too perfect for my flux talk to not talk
about
way before maui was ever announced and
anything else like that
and it just fits so perfectly within the
this design pattern because it's really
the structure that it was meant to be we
now have the unidirectional data flow
from flux for our data structure and we
have the unidirectional data flow
of local state within any component that
we want
and it's just like the perfect combo of
being able to track things
compose your views and just make
everything work um
so that's that's all i wanted to to show
you all today
uh thank you for joining um i'm i'm
always streaming on twitch now sundays
and wednesdays so if you want to hop in
and talk about
uh tech or or sort of watching the the
cool projects we're building definitely
join me is twitch.tv
swab underscore pirate just like the
twitter handle um
we just built a alexa powered controller
using arduino and
net to be able to control our character
and call of duty by just yelling at our
alexa device we're always doing some
pretty cool stuff
but thank you all for coming thank you
for joining and thanks for uh everyone
participated in chat uh and i hope you
enjoy the rest of ndc oslo and i'll be
around in slack all day too so you know
feel free to dm me with any other
questions or thoughts or anything like
that
i'll be in the hallway track as well
yeah thank you everyone